yes j'ai tous mes vieux sms au hall à
houla là j'ai toutes les notifications
qui arrivent d'un coup
ok ok ok ok ok on se calme
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous aider à transférer
vos photos vos données vos messages
whatsapp vos photos à de sape de votre
iphone iphone 10 s max pourquoi pas
iphone ce que vous voulez vers samsung
ou alors en tout cas plus largement vers
un appareil android c'est une vidéo qui
est sponsorisé par wonder cher et je
vous présente cette solution parce
qu'elle a un vrai sens qu'elle peut
vraiment venir vous aider
lorsque vous voulez faire comme j'ai
fait il ya pas très longtemps passé d'un
iphone dans mon cas c'est un iphone si
c'est ce vers un android pour ma part
c'était en bonne place 6 t aujourd'hui
c'est un google pixels 3 et une solution
comme celle du rhône de recherche
vraiment intéressante pourquoi parce
qu'à vous permet de le faire facilement
sans bug sans galérer et ça c'est bien
alors il existe d'autres solutions mais
celle là je trouve intéressant vous avez
tout sur un seul et même panneau ça
marche c'est efficace c'est cool donc du
coup je vous la présente donc
aujourd'hui on va bosser directement sur
mon macbook pro comme tous les macbook
pro le problème c'est que tout est en
port usb c'est du court là il faut qu'on
passe par un hub j'ai mon petit peuple
targus qui est la tac je prends hop je
branche
voilà donc ce que je veux faire je veux
me grey 2 mon iphone que j'ai branché
directement la vère directement en non
notre téléphone qui est là donc là j'ai
une option qui s'appelle migrer je vais
donc cliquer sur migrer ça va me
permettre de migrer de mon iphone
directement vers n'importe quel iphone
vers n'importe quel smartphone android
donc hop je veux me grey ça m'ouvre la
petite partie migrer des logiciels dr
von j'en profite pour brancher mon
deuxième téléphone directement tac tac
en usb c'est ensuite je regarde
directement ce que je veux transférer on
va par là dessus comme je suis déjà
synchronisé avec google j'ai déjà
récupéré des photos j'ai déjà récupéré
des contacts pas mal de choses car
qu'est-ce qui manque là dedans
ce sont tous mes messages c'est
l'historique de mes appels c'est toutes
ces choses là et là je peux récupérer de
plein de choses directement là dessus
que ça c'est vraiment cool donc les
contacts je décoche les messages textes
je les garde
le calendrier c'est pareil c'est google
n'a pas besoin le journal d'appels je le
garde les photos j'ai déjà de google
photo pareil pour les vidéos donc là
j'ai récup
deux choses qui me manquaient qui sont
essentiels et qui par contre ne peuvent
pas être transférés directement avec les
services google c'est les messages texte
et le journal d'appels je fais commencé
le transfert confirmé la fnaut qui
s'amusent à noter en appuyant sur wii
que dois-je faire on brûle la nonière
changer d'application pour les sms
utilisait connector au lieu de messages
comme application sms c'est donc un
réglage temporaire je clique sur ok je
fais continuer et là ça va tout le
transférer je commence le transfert je
vais donc avoir tous mes sms qui vont
être transférés tous mon journal
d'appels qui va être transférée là
dedans ça permet de récupérer tout le
monde historique
et ça franchement c'est cool parce que
au jour d'aujourd'hui mise à part ça je
ne connais pas de solution qui permet de
transférer ces données là directement de
mon iphone vers un smartphone android
donc là c'est bon la copie est terminée
réussite ou échec 0 donc ça veut dire
que maintenant dans mon téléphone je
dois avoir tout le monde historique
liesse j'ai tous mes vieux sms au hall à
houla là j'ai plus que les autres estime
thierry lincou
ok ok ok ok ok on se calme bah ça c'est
vachement bien ça franchement c'est
hyper cool parce que voyez j'ai changé
de téléphone ya pas très longtemps j'ai
eu des pendant un temps sur le monde
plus systématiquement je me fais le
google pixels 3 et ça me manquait tout
ccns donc c'était un peu la galère est
donc là c'est pareil pour mon journal
d'appels
j'ai tout mon journal d'appels donc ça
franchement c'est super cool
voilà ça arrive pour ça c'est vraiment
une solution qui franchement bien et je
vous dis cette solution et ça pas
uniquement à ça elle vous ça peut
transférer toutes vos photos directement
des os sur android ça marche super bien
mais on ne s'arrête pas là parce que
maintenant on peut continuer maintenant
une autre option qu intéressant qui
s'appelle restaurer sociale apte vous
permet de sauvegarder et de restaurer
tout vous donnez whatsapp vous donner
viber et compass dictée exactement de la
même manière à pouvoir transférer des
messages whatsapp sauvegarder des
messages whatsapp restaurer des messages
whatsapp sans votre appareil ios ou
allons restaurer des messages ou aux
sables sur votre appareil android
donc ça vous pouvez le faire directement
pour moi c'est en tout cas ce qu'on voit
est ce qui est super intéressant avec
une solution comme celle à dr von j'en
ai déjà parlé je pense que logiciel est
assez intéressant parce qu'il permet de
faire pas mal de choses en termes de
sauvegarde en termes d'utilisation de
transfert au niveau de vos smartphones
c'est franchement bien et souvent on
gagne à passer dans smartphone à l'autre
grâce à google
grâce à des solutions dans le cloud ça
permet de pallier à certains problèmes
les typiquement les messages et les
journaux d'appels ça c'est pas possible
donc ça c'est plutôt cool dites moi ce
que vous en pensez de cette solution de
wonder cher dr von est-ce que vous avez
déjà rencontré ces problèmes et au final
est-ce qu'un logiciel comme celui là
pourrait vous solutionner pas mal de
problèmes et vous aider vous marquez
tout ça en commentaire je vous invite
bien évidemment à consulter à d'autres
vidéos de ce genre pour vous aider pour
tous vos problèmes liés à votre
smartphone et à rester connectés parce
qu'on va parler toujours plus de
solutions liées aux smartphones doit
parler de smartphones en de même on en a
beaucoup en test donc ça c'est cool
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui je
vous embrasse prenez soin de vous et à
très bientôt
ciao